alors ça avance pardon
on commence à avancer oui est content
oui bah ouais ça se dessine
à l'estadi que je connaissais très bien
nagé non non je savais pas mon père a
été en poste là-bas pendant plusieurs
années d'accord donc toi avant d'écrire
sable noir tu étais jamais allé là bas
n'ont jamais jamais jamais jamais c'est
troublant les détails la description à
quoi ça j'ai fait beaucoup de recherches
en fait beaucoup documentation j'imagine
et là tu écris sur quoi enfin si c'est
par un décret tendance un discret mais
là c'est encore un petit peu tôt pour le
dire je comprends avec le deuxième c'est
toujours le plus dur tu dois avoir la
pression non